in 2010 this man forrest fenn hit a
chest filled with gold and rare
artifacts somewhere in the rocky
mountains
the search for this million-dollar
treasure has obsessed thousands of
seekers worldwide
and the trail starts with this poem
which fenn wrote
it contains nine clues that point to the
treasure's location it's here someplace
where are we rolling
as i have gone alone in there and with
my treasures bowl i can keep my secret
where and hen of riches new and old
fenn's motivation for hiding the
treasure was to give hope to those
knocked down by the recession and to
inspire them to explore the wild
i found a beautiful little romanesque
treasure chest and i started filling it
up with with gold coins and gold nuggets
and about 280 rubies
there are two salon sapphires there are
eight emeralds a bunch of diamonds but
mostly gold
i don't know what it's worth and i don't
even want to think about that you're not
going to be disappointed if you find
that treasure chest
i'm cynthia meacham and i am a full-time
treasure hunter
i have been
looking for fenn's treasure now for a
little over three and a half years
i head to treasure chest
more than 8.25 miles north of santa fe
in the rocky mountains someplace
nobody knows but me
the poem that you have to solve forrest
always said you have to find where warm
waters halt and to me this is where our
warm waters halt
that's where i think that we need to
find the treasure chest
the thrill of this chase for fenn's
treasure has led many to leave the
safety of known trails and well-beaten
paths
the mountains are very unforgiving
it's extremely important that you know
what you're doing and you know where
you're going
you can end up in big trouble really
quickly
there's even one hiker that's been lost
looking for the treasure and he hasn't
been found yet
to fenn's knowledge the treasure remains
a hidden mystery
but the real reward should come from the
hunt
i was positive this was our warm waters
halt
and unfortunately i just i don't think
that this is going to be the spot
it doesn't matter what state you
treasure hunt in you're going to have
beautiful scenery like this
and it doesn't matter if you find a
treasure chest or not this is finding
the treasure
right here
so hear me all and listen good your
effort will be worth the coal if you are
brave and in the wood
i give you title to the gold
you